en el último vídeo la hipótesis nula fue
que el fármaco no tenía efecto y la
hipótesis alternativa era que el fármaco
si tenía un efecto no planteamos si el
fármaco subía el tiempo de respuesta o
bajaba el tiempo de respuesta
simplemente planteamos que el fármaco
tiene un efecto que la media al aplicar
el fármaco iba a ser distinta a la media
de la población mientras que la
hipótesis nula decía no la media la
plica del fármaco es la misma que la
media de la población no había un efecto
en este caso en el que estamos probando
tan solo si hay un efecto y hace un
efecto extremo positivo o un efecto
extremo negativo simplemente es que hay
un efecto estamos aplicando lo que se
conoce como una prueba de dos colas
prueba de dos colas lo que se conoce
como prueba
y dos colas porque francamente si
hubiéramos tenido también un tiempo de
respuesta excesivamente largo un tiempo
más allá de tres desviaciones estándar
hubiéramos también rechazado la
hipótesis nula
estamos tomando en cuenta entonces las
dos colas hubiéramos podido realizar una
prueba de hipótesis similar con el mismo
experimento la cual fuera una prueba de
una sola cola y la manera hacer esto
sería la siguiente la hipótesis nula no
cambia la hipótesis nula es que no hay
efecto al aplicar el fármaco el fármaco
no tiene efecto el fármaco no tiene
efecto o podemos plantear lo que la
media y luego pone así la media con el
fármaco sigue siendo igual a 1.2
segundos el tiempo medio de respuesta
ahora si queremos hacer una prueba de
una sola cola supongamos que por alguna
razón sabemos que el fármaco baja el
tiempo de respuesta entonces nuestra
hipótesis alternativa sería y para que
te familiarices con otro tipo de
notación que aparece en libros o que
usan maestros la hipótesis alternativa
se puede notar
por h subíndice 1 o h subíndice a ambas
están bien entonces en este caso la
hipoteca alternativa sería que el
fármaco baja la respuesta el fármaco
baja la respuesta o lo que es lo mismo
que la media con el fármaco va a ser
menor a 1.2 segundos
ahora cuando quieres ser una prueba de
una cola como ésta lo que tienes que
pensar lo que tienes que tomar en cuenta
es lo siguiente si aquí tenemos nuestra
distribución muestral de hecho voy a
usar la que teníamos acá arriba tenemos
nuestra institución muestral
tenemos aquí nuestra media de 1.2
segundos que corresponde a la na y la
instrucción muestral tenemos nuestra
desviación estándar que calculamos aquí
usando la desviación estándar de la
muestra lo cual pudimos hacer pues el
tamaño de muestra es mayor que 30 lo que
garantiza que la distribución muestral
es normal y usando esto vimos que
nuestro resultado la media muestral de
1.0 5 segundos se encontraba a tres
desviaciones estándar por abajo de la
media está tres desviaciones estándar
por abajo de la media déjame hacerlo
ahora sí aquí abajo
aquí tenemos nuestra distribución
muestral
aquí tenemos nuestra media que es igual
a 1.2 segundos y nuestro resultado
experimental que vimos que se encuentra
a 3 desviaciones estándar por abajo de
la media 123 desviaciones estándar aquí
tenemos nuestro valor experimental que
es 1.0 5 segundos ahora cuando lo
planteas de esta manera no tan solo
dices que el fármaco tiene un impacto
como ya hicimos que tuvimos que ver
ambas colas sino que establece es que el
fármaco baja el tiempo de respuesta y
así como hicimos en el caso anterior
supongamos que el fármaco no baja el
tiempo de respuesta entonces suponiendo
que el fármaco no baja el tiempo de
respuesta cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener un valor tan pequeño o más
extremo que este entonces en este caso
solo consideraremos esta cola cuando
planteamos nuestra hipótesis pensando en
que baja el tiempo de respuesta así sí
nuestra hipótesis nula es verdadera
cuál es la probabilidad
de obtener un resultado más extremo
1.0 5 segundos ahora estamos
considerando tan solo esta cola aquí la
podría obtener resultado más extremo o
menor que 1.05 vamos a describirlo
porque en el vídeo anterior consideramos
valores más extremos inclusive un valor
alto decíamos está bien es distinto de
1.2 yo a lo que queremos en la
probabilidad obtener un resultado que
sea menor menor que 1.0 5 segundos
es lo mismo que obtener una muestra de
la distribución muestral cuya media se
ubique a más de tres desviaciones
estándar por debajo de la media y la
distribución muestral y en este caso
sólo vamos a considerar ya en una cola
en esta cola así que esta va a ser una
prueba de una sola cola en la cual sólo
nos interesa la dirección abajo de la
media y si vemos el resultado que
obtuvimos aquí con la puede dos colas
donde obtuvimos que la polis de estas
dos áreas combinadas era punto 3 %
entonces debido a la asimetría de la
distribución normal aquí vamos a tener
la mitad es decir vamos a tener
estaré aquí va a ser igual a 0.15
por ciento o si lo expresamos en
fracción esta va a ser 0.00 15 de nueva
cuenta entonces si estableces de tus
hipótesis cómo estás entonces la
conclusión es si tu hipótesis nula es
correcta
habrá una probabilidad de punto 15% de
obtener un resultado que sea menor al
que obtuvimos eso es improbable por lo
cual vamos a rechazar
rechazamos
la hipótesis nula y vamos por la
hipótesis alternativa y en este caso el
valor p el valor p va a ser igual a
punto 0 015